- [Man] If somebody is extremely
passionate about something that
doesn't come naturally to them,--
- Yes.
- should they not pursue it
because it's not a strength or
should they go for it anyway
because they love that shit?
- Bro, I'm so pumped you
asked this question.
I'm glad we're getting
to say it here.
If you're not great at it
but you love it more than life
should you go after it?
To me, the answer is yes.
- [Man] Hell yeah, hell yeah.
- The problem is please
also recognize you're
probably not gonna get rich.
If you love basketball
more than life,
it's just what you always loved,
you might just make
$49,000 a year being a
basketball coach and having
a lot of time on your hands
to play basketball.
It's just you got to understand,
you can't have everything
all the time, always.
It's just life.
I think happiness
trumps everything.
Easy for me to say because
it really worked out for me.
'Cause happiness coincides
with financial upside.
I have friends who make
$74,000 a year that are just
happier people than
friends that are making
$18 million a year that are not.
You've got to do you but
please don't let the
entrepreneurial society, don't
let me, don't let your parents
push you in to what success is.
It's different for all of us.
But, and this is the big but,
you've got to be
self-aware about it.
(upbeat electronica music)